[Musik]
zürich west
mitten in der stadt lebt hier eine
gruppe von frauen und männern völlig
anders als üblich die gruppe lebt nicht
in einer normalen wohnung
sie lebt in einer halle
beim sogenannten hallen wohnen bauen die
bewohnerinnen und bewohner eine
gewerbehalle zum lebensraum
[Musik]
mit bewohnern und atelier nutzern gehen
hier rund 20 personen ein und aus je
nach nutzung bezahlen sie 200 bis 700
franken monatsmiete
[Musik]
das ist auf 700 quadratmetern wird
sollten sich franken pro monat und
seelische sie dass man die halle
möglichst offen gespielt mit rollbare
spaces wo man schlafen und adele
plattform zu schaffen
[Musik]
das space die flucht wie so luftig wie
es immer ist wo aber damit bin ich
eigentlich fehlt
[Musik]
links und rechts vom bett gekommen zu
machen
und also praktisch wenn der vorhang zur
schweren koffer und wetterlage sie und
dann rund aufzuhalten klopfer das
funktioniert inklusive und ich bin hier
seit jahren nicht mehr anders können
trasse östlich nach und macht die sache
nicht leichter aber es bringt nicht die
eigenen band immer maintal iii gewann
die an ihm selber sport und darum wird
die eigentlich auch so manch ein wenig
eigen der wand bohren und nicht mehr
verkaufen
[Musik]
die möglichkeiten die das leben in einer
halle mit sich bringt sind der
wichtigste grund so zu leben
ich habe lange zeit gesagt habe wurden
für mich wohler unterlief 1
[Musik]
wenn man eben ein neuer ort buchen zum
zuhören den kameraden so vermieden
werden bin ich das gefühl veranstaltung
also der ortes oder andere nach den
bedürfnissen wohnung erhängt
verletzt
dass man zur 18
aber man hat also muss ich mich freunde
das ist eine grundvoraussetzung ist so
funktioniert's nicht dass man sich doch
besonders wenn tausend berge und wenn
das so ist dann ist das familiäre
stimmung mitteilt für miteinander also
ist das für mich auch sich bewohner
hatten die haben immer gefunden haben
sind dann waren mit in eine klinik sie
und noch mal dritter oder vierter jetzt
habe ich mir viel sondern mehr mit
anderen analyt und anderen inputs
verbunden blieben
und da haben wir jetzt sehr viel und sie
in verschiedenen im putz und chris das
was machen sie zählen bilder unter dem
motto was bringe dann wenn die
schwimmerin viertelstunde auf stunden
oder länger
[Musik]
das hallen wohnen mit kindern bedingte
dass die familie nebst dem holz immer
auch ein abgetrenntes zimmer im hinteren
teil der halle hat das team kann sich
noch so sehr wichtig wurde gerade auf
und ab jetzt man nun also der rückzug
aus ganze familie und inode ich super
auf einmal ist können sich das gar nicht
vorstellen und ich bin zu 8000 dadurch
haben wir das gar nicht vorstellen für
die umgekehrte situation
[Musik]
diese art zu wohnen ist momentan nur
inzwischen nutzung möglich der
mietvertrag war von beginn weg auf
dreieinhalb jahre befristet in wenigen
monaten müssen die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner ausziehen an einer
sonntäglichen wg sitzung wird der
zeitplan des kommenden abbaus diskutiert
so stecken so da müssen wir noch eine
frühe und mit guter letzt die
persönliche gründe und den schlüssel
abgeben
zu seiner frau gesagt wieso zusage ihres
zypries am gegen 22.10 persönlich
sondern helfen einem reisfeld suchen
hunt vom tricks angetrunken gefahren war
und zyklen und lockere
während die meisten als nächstes in eine
wohnung ziehen werden hat matschie
größere pläne
das projekt hatte man die zur real war
wunderbar klappt und gewürgt und wir
hoffen immer dann in zukunft eintreten
eine längerfristige gesetzte drama ist
wo man aber die gleiche
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten und freiheit
hat wie wir in temporäre nutzung
ganz in der nähe des zürcher
hauptbahnhofs wo bauland knapp und
begehrt ist entsteht die siedlung
zollhaus bauherrin ist die zürcher
wohnbaugenossenschaft kalkbreite hier
soll zum ersten mal offiziell das hallen
wohnen in einem wohngebäude angeboten
werden das ausprobieren hohes c und da
ein who is our wird eine abitur als
hannover stattfinden
aus aller welt ein drittel so teuer wie
ein toller wurf der innenhof los und da
ist die alte halle wo erwarte ausschluss
hat dem innenhof und die leute wirken
zufall sind nutzer bahnhof eine soziale
verantwortung
besonders seine stelle als 08 15 xp
rendite ab schützen
das quartier winter als christus macht
wir haben uns bilder von perus oder
minder prominente lachen
dann soll das haus über ganz viele jungs
können und wo das aufhören also
entsprechend groß gruppenarbeit große
wohnung mehr werfer durchlässig ist um
ihn damit neue ideen von bohlen und die
erste siedlung der genossenschaft
kalkbreite hat neue maßstäbe für
alternative wohnformen und nachhaltiges
autofreies leben gesetzt
hier besucht matty eine besprechung zum
hallen wohnen auch andere gruppen sind
interessierte herzlich willkommen zu der
zwischen besprechen caron es nur darum
geht ja was für fragen steht den nets
neuen ruhm für die bewerbung wo man ja
dann erwartet auf der er steht selber
kommen wir über leid wäre theoretisch
möglich flasche zu salzig installiert wo
man zum beispiel liegen wir es beethoven
oder so es ist eine idee dass man
eventuell auch bucht kommt einer aus
wohneinheit
wenn durchsetzt fällt mir die container
bevor man fassade montiert dann müsstest
du dein zahler wärme die container mit
reflexen
ist eine geordnete nicht alle hat mir
das haus gebaut wie der bauch schnell
glaubt jetzt 20 die konzepte werbick
darum dass sich gruppe bildet wo welche
zusammen wohnen aber nicht nur über das
reduzierte zahl von der reform eine dose
finde was für sozial dommusik dass die
hand wie dicht werden sie wohnen
wie werden sie sich finanzieren und wir
werden sie das auch über zwei jahre
grüne bewohner wo sie den mieterwechsel
itc
das wird sich heraus druck sollte die
gruppe jetzt sag jetzt mal die formale
teilen wir die finanzierung mit den
serien geleistet untereinander abkaufen
was für was der regel etabliert
untereinander dass man eine sehr viel
geschafft hat und nach zwei jahren
klinikum berlin auswanderer und so dass
sie alles geheim leben oder das leben
irgendwie auch massen entscheidet wer
vor hat darüber dass es dann einfach
klar ausgesprochen erster wechsel die
gruppe die großen anteil
seit eben wenig komplex um die große
konflikt weil wir die reitet man
natürlich nicht gern über das wetter das
thema es ist auch ein nationaler worte
und so sein da haben wir das kurz die im
zimmer carbon ebenso für große konflikt
hat und nur noch linie und die firma
manager das ist der nachteil dass sie
schon sich sehr dicht mannheim ich mit
allen vibes direkt konfrontiert machen
mit überschlag oder wolfsburg hat und
man saubere software im level ich also
mein hund sehr viel mit über 5 vom
kollektiv das sich an als ob sie das
nachdem hais nach ende der haft für alle
oder so und das ist super oder
dann erwacht ist und lust offline
gestellt und dann halt gerade
schwangerschafts übertrat gekocht und
dann vielleicht nicht so lustig und das
gleiche ich habe mit rinder- oder dass
der ganze stress wo halt durch und
und dann hätte die banane gekauft
das kann einem die nerven und viel reiz
aber meistens viel mehr waren eingekauft
hätten
[Musik]
aufgewachsen sind die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner wie die meisten leute
konventionell benehmen zurück um eine
bürgerlich setting ein faktor charts key
sprach sie von dem vater menschliche
komponente stark sie nicht mehr sagte
glock sie liegt direkt am wald man hat
viele freiheiten 140 kinder wo
versteckspiel ist viel wenn man dieser
zeuge auf der wald und und naturen platz
ich habe früh bietet bis zum
gehtnichtmehr unter dem vorplatz
heimatland und genialer pass ich bin
einfach der steinbock sie der schule und
einem gemieteten bus - brachte müssen
sagt normale familie 2002 familie muss
keine karte und dann wenn im august war
die frühe und sich ein wenig mehr
zurückzog
ich glaube jetzt kennt er bezwingt und
boni in das studentenheim des risikos
sie logisch sonst ist er los
betriebsprüfer fragen und auch danach
nicht mehr anders
und das macht spaß das ist ein rohling
space aber es hat keine rede
alex hat 100 systemdesign und gewalt so
weit überhaupt sowie brenntag und die
vierbeiner kommen raus und alles hätte
ein bisschen so meinen die valley
unterlassen und dann können wir dieses
ziel erreichen braucht viel kraft
[Musik]
der nebel person die quadratmeter hat
dann haben wir alles die hälfte vor der
halle und die andere hälfte ist
veranstaltungen machen dass man wieder
friedlich irgendwie ihr tag war und im
normalfall den oder ist austria hat eine
beziehungstat metern
[Musik]
regelmäßig öffnen die hallenbäder innen
und bewohner ihren privaten raum für
einen größeren kreis von menschen und
veranstalten konzerte ausstellungen
theateraufführungen und performance
[Musik]
die öffentliche bestätigung oder
halbstaatlichen die sind immer das thema
klar dass das nicht nur für diesen ruhm
ist groß dass es ein offenes
denn den branchen die viel ging
[Musik]
das beste zum abschied ist die trennung
ist natürlich und ich finde dann aber
umso mehr umso besser umso mehr input
vor ostern wurde ich da wieder vor der
täglichen arbeit ablagen der plan
zeichner konzept erstellen und ich hoffe
sie also 100% momentane vier direkt am
haus und muss gleichzeitig betreuen
das haben heute frei zugänglichen
abschalten sie wird aber für waffen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das rouge zum beispiel all der stress
vom aufbau von vom organisieren und nach
los buchse weil ich bin putzen
das ist lässig sie und es hat uns wieder
einmal zusammengebracht und rutschende
moment wo ein irgendwie trägt oder sind
so höhepunkt neben wir einander reichen
herrlichen
[Musik]
in einer waldhütte in der nähe von
zürich verbringt matty ein wochenende
mit einer neuen gruppe von leuten mit
denen er an der bewerbung für das hallen
wohnen im zollhaus arbeitet wir sind
jetzt wieder die sygnis diskussion und
die grundlegend um wo es am schluss
einfach die beruflich zwei rollen plus
clubs das gönne ich packe in die
festhalle franz interessanter als die
großen wollen wir verschiedene benutzer
blu rays das kann ich dir weiter sicher
dass er schließlich aber ich spüre den
schlaf bringen wo die luft isoliert ist
und blickdicht auch ein update sie so
eine organisch gewachsen die komponente
muss ein platz wo man probiert dann
macht es halt anders definitiv um
gemeinsam kleiderschrank lightroom wird
wenn ich also die idee dass man eine
station die politik uns wählt weiß roten
das spiel sehen wir stehen wir das
wirklich dimensionale konstruktion von
leitungen und hängebrücke zwischen
cluster sowie trend ist tabu zone
physischen sicherheit beim sterben ist
meine akkus mit einer offenen welt
sondern die erfahrungen in der praxis
des hallen wohnens müssen hier den weg
in ein theoretisches konzept finden
meine vorstellung ist dass eine schlaffe
das minimum reduzieren und du darfst
noch aber ein großer öffentlicher
allgemeiner und grüne bei mir sohnes
ideal für absolute fairness wird
ausschreiben müssen extrem kompliziert
die kalkulation vorne
die sich anhören muss generiert werden
er traut sich sparen
kostbar bedeutet die monatsmiete bei den
beiden hallen beträgt für 300
quadratmeter circa 9000 franken
die diskussionen wieder raum genutzt und
die miete verteilt werden soll dauern
bis spät in die nacht leisten gehören
vielleicht verdichtet gebaut
wie findet man sollte andere findet
werden so dass weniger platz brauchen
pro person und ich finde man sollte
einfach bei bestehen die combo da ist
zeitlich gestaffelt nutzer und einfach
intelligent nutzen und das ist so das
halt projekt war das rennteam auch dass
man einfach sagen laut mitteilung
es gibt verschiedenste lüth war der
google nutzt aber nicht richtig
wenn er wüsste der werden wir waren
jetzt die bewilligung dauer durch oder
das von salut halle wohnen zu klappen
wir wieder das kohleprojekt aufbauen und
ich vermute dass mir alles brauchbare zu
werden und der nutzer welle war so
scharf geschaltet und vielleicht dann
doch noch was sie gemacht hat und
schlägt eine druckstelle holz nichts
machen
gestatten möglichkeit ja das ist sie so
viel viel lachen und denken wir da
nachlässig irgendwie und sowieso geplant
und zu kompliziert für mich also ist es
ist super so eine krankheit in zufikon
seiten zur ideologie diversifikation in
halle das wird aber es wird sicher super
aber das so klar so ein konzept gefunden
dass wir die freiheit die ich nie
gemacht werden
die bohrmaschine und los ist - 40
neben der salzgasse ohne jetzt sehr
langen tag hoffe dass er vor lauter
konzept vor wenn er als ist eine und
abwasser und der ganzen zeit und
harmonie stettler einen hersteller
stellt sein buch vielleicht komisch also
stress vor sagen soll
die cdu mache und der schweiz haben sich
in einer phase da schlafen wir als
bisher stimmt das
es ist der tag der
bewerbungspräsentation vor der
kalkbreite jury betty ist schon da sein
arbeitsort ist nämlich in der kalkbreite
siedlung seit 17 jahren arbeitete er als
umweltwissenschaftler für greenpeace
damit machen us körperschaft firma zum
beispiel große stadt und auch der wurst
wright gerechtigkeit über nach der
großbrief tage vor dem start vom
diesjährige wef in davos hat
international ein report veröffentlicht
zum umwelt- verbraucher- und überhaupt
man zurück und so bildet die vertreter
von mehr als 30 will sich sehr intensiv
merkt man die globale ebene greenpeace
hatte ganz lokal mit bar und bei den
zukunftsvisionen zum wohle wenigstens
nicht wählen
außerdem hoffen wir dass es ihr gut geht
mit der präsentation
jetzt entscheidet sich ob max gruppe mit
dem namen zur wolke eine zukunft im
zollhaus hat
das sind 29 personen wir sind zwar frau
elf männer und auch trinkt familie
kommen
ich brauche für promis dabei und zwar
modular und mobile familie tun würde das
dann gestaltet wichtige sprechers
erwähnt man als große bad und wc plane
zwar wirklich für mehrere liter weit ist
und dass ich eben genau mit einer der
ordner dass mit ihr zwei
unterschiedlichen gestaltet dass ich aus
dem konzept und dass wir ausfüllen
brauche die honig willen die krise
bedürfe es abdeckt wo mir sucht einfach
wir nicht richtig von optik setzt ruf
oder hat es also kein gruppe so
beschloss und angesprochen dass jeder
ein startkapital idee freilich bringt
dass wir wieder um in jeder situation
sieht vor 10 15 jahren zurückzahlen
derzeit seien sich franka pro kopf
gerechnet ihr seltener bereit das ganze
jetzt ins risiko für zwei jahre um den
honig zu träge und zu der leerstand
allgemeinmedizin und glied in einer zwei
halbbrüder vieles passieren können dass
träger wieder trifft und liegt wieder
ein projekt mitmachen
der verein sterben verpflichtet ich habe
die gedanken wie sie machen das haben
wir heute kein gruppe elftes diskutiert
über die stände wie wir hören zusammen
weitere gruppe an wir haben schon andere
gruppen an
wird das heißt es gibt eine auswahl wir
werden uns zusammensetzen in den
nächsten tagen und bräuchen rücken
hingeben
das sehen die konzepte im rennen und hat
gruppe d b da sehen innenarchitektur
studiert studentinnen total interessant
weil sie sehr strukturell und die holen
könnte
man merkt aber dass roger hoffmann sie
einfach viel wohl und auf erfahrung im
kollektiven das lässt sich drachen und
damals ganz besonders konzept wichtig um
familie gott und halle wo jetzt der
wettbewerber hat das geht wirklich haben
aber auch schon mal prinz wo das
grundkonzept haben fußball weil sie böse
das buch 13 anspruch darauf kann sich
aber durchaus um rein ja bei dir wird
für diese häuser vollständig auf sich
doppelt so viel kostet mich sind jetzt
auch offen um zu erreichen dass es am
anfang
senioren könnte wie sie
ich habe spaß kommt muss man sich damals
einige dass die sender sie und dass man
sie jetzt als die nächste
dass mir da nicht so will dieser
bildungs probieren
[Musik]
eher als salbe mehrwert februar letztes
mal bekommt der fußball kommission und
der stadt angesichts dieser
umfangreichen vorbehalte können wir das
konzept zur wolke im bewerbungsprozess
nicht weiter berücksichtigen
das ist natürlich mit aller härte
schlagen
wir sind wirklich der wohnkomfort
zerstört weil ich einfach kochen und
schlafen und ich persönlich davon in der
familie und frauen bei der kinder eine
logische fortsetzung aus dem ganzen
anlagen zur vergangenheit weil die idee
wie sie kristallisierte manifestieren
und tagesschau und wollte es ist schon
die größte indische polizei
[Musik]
sie haben ganz viel ruhm bei jena seine
zwei hunde und neubau nick und ich das
ist schon wichtige faktor dass es mit
uns nicht überzeugt hat wie so dass sie
dir bedürfnis was ihr breites bedürfnis
auch klick macht dann noch nicht
schafften aber in das konzept den es
auch tektonisch konzepte bootsführer wo
er innerhalb von horne zu realisieren
ich würde das wohl irritiert hat mit
ihrer hormone erfahrung machen danke das
ist eine farblose ja der umgang mit
rüben und ruhezone und leerung zone und
wir haben die verschiedenen bedürfnisse
innere vor allem roma abbilde
das muss wirklich sagen dass die anderen
gruppen es geschafft haben mit ihren
unterlagen und ihrer präsentation eine
vision aufleben zu lassen die wir vor
unseren augen sehen konnten
und da sind die zur welt leider zu
diffus geblieben ist dass das hätte
glauben können
es bleibt noch ein monat bis zum auszug
die letzte gemeinsame putzaktion läuft
also das machen das hier nur auf wesen
gemacht
[Musik]
mit dabei
ganz verschwitzt internet sie hat die
hoffnung auf das hallen wohnen im
zollhaus noch nicht aufgegeben und hat
mit der projektgruppe zur wolke um eine
aussprache mit der jury gebeten
xxx dagegen wir sind geschockt
funkel oder regen spur einer
gesichtswahrenden lösung
und jetzt über eine sprache doch
irgendwie dass das positiv wird sie das
filmteam wurde gebeten während der
aussprache keine tonaufnahmen zu machen
ich fühle mich gedemütigt einmal weg man
hat jetzt auch schluss frage stellt kann
falls die beide teams noch im rennen
sind was sie würde durch die apps würden
erwägen und wo ich mir da antworte ich
ziemlich negativ sie würde jetzt lieber
legen wir glauben dir oder sauber machen
und das ein aufführung
ich finde es nach frau wirklich versucht
sage dass mir der russe der ruhm als ein
sozialer roma blockt handel nur als
architektonische gestaltung folgen wie
viel meter halle und das mir vermisse
das ist kein großer muss mit trainer das
bleibe ich finde das wirklich skandalös
ich finde das total engagiert spielen
auch wenn es keine zukunft im zollhaus
zu geben scheint die hallen
bewohnerinnen und bewohner müssen
abbauen
passend zum thema auszug erscheinen alle
ausgezogen zum sonntag plötzlich da
draußen
50 und dann meine zeitung south china
morning post
1 -60 eigentlich klar das ist ein
schnitt frieda aber dass ich nicht für
ihn bestimmt gab es wichtig ist mit
stattlichen wir andere gemeinschaft und
die immobilie chance so dass trotz eines
wohn und das mit ihr ist und dass man
die erwähnt gibt
[Musik]
wir haben super league runde und siebter
an die csu versuche sich haben normale
gesellschaft hoch ideen und alles
funktioniert
das ist komisch aber dass ich auch nicht
an stationen als wir sind immer auf der
suche nach halle wo es passt und
irgendwie funktioniert wenn er sein
internetformat ihren heissig lupe am
heißesten
[Applaus]
wir haben jetzt über uns lustig fand in
einer anderen halle gefunden wäre es in
der kita
das war möglich kriegt dann darf es auch
einander dass es mindestens 1000
anbieter sind wir sozusagen der zone
main der als nette frau malte wir sind
da nicht auch ein bisschen auch die
gemeinschaft und der wohnung wo mit
wohnsitz hat und eben wie kindisches
über mögliche schwächen wie schorlemmer
spd oder wohnsitz hat
das böse auch gepackt
für mich kommt der ruben gar nicht
zutreffe dass man sich nicht unbedingt
der haller sie des charakters relativ
man muss das glück der menschen kennt
man zusammenlebt
egal welche konstellation das für mich
noch wichtiger aus architektur
allerdings um die zukunft geht
und ja das sollte jetzt steht und so ist
das guck mal was sonst nichts kunst
[Musik]
das soll sie war nicht
wir haben zwar die tageshochs sind nach
214 im schlafzimmer also müssen sie wege
da die klinik und sie haben normal
evonik sieht wie sie waren dass er dem
parkett das würde ich nicht so wie ford
hat ja schon oft bis an das thema ist
wenn du wie zerstören was ist mit noch
da aber es ist wirklich angespannt
aussah betrachtet nach riesen gusto
trotzdem irgendwie snowboarden oder
bisher ist es ist das ist eine recht
entspannt zum wohnen in eine normale
wohnung kinetik für sich selber wenn man
nicht die ganze noch im gleichen raum wo
man beim veranstalter gemacht und
setzinger und immer wieder gruppen habe
seiner macht
wir führen die freizeit so dass märkte
wirklich arbeit mehr hand hat keine roma
im moment zu machen und diese würden
also irgendwas ist immer daneben fielen
roberto man kochen oder putzen oder
musik wasser
das sei aber häufig nach
microsoft stand jahrelang der messe
ich glaube die blume motorradausfahrt
teil sondern macht natürlich mit 91
[Musik]
das ist großes thema ob sie das ja und
mehr zwei gruppen aus berka einer
sektorstudie hier hat fröhlich flugzeuge
familie steht klipp und klar dass blond
und das ist den job beim sind machen wir
den bewerbungsprozess normalen
kompletten
die bieter
für dusche ich machen soll die maximale
unterteilung des staates 2xl wo man
bisher ausgeschrieben werden zwei alte
halle 2 1 und 2 zu schweben und auch
ganz neu ist dass die gruppe das ist
beweist der ganz bewilligungs prozess
nicht mitmachen
die ganze bautechnische planeten sondern
eigentlich letztendlich nur noch mit
innenarchitektonische frage konfrontiert
sind ihre honige ganze bautechnische
namen erinnern
wir haben mit einem ganzen prozess sehr
viel klärt und müssen realisieren dass
man ein stück des blauäugigen der
prozesse gegangen sind und überschätzt
was man eine bringt wie zu selbst
organisierte gruppe wo ihren unterricht
ja die information hatte scott lady
erreicht und stress gestützt
meine hand immer noch hoffnung dass es
am schluss siegen die möglichkeit gibt
rolle spielt deshalb nicht auszunutzen
jetzt noch mal die ganzen wurf geht wir
sind da auf die philippinen auf rechlin
insel und erlaubt so gut mit dem motor
eigentliche familie strand meer und
jungen
es ist es ein zimmermädchen abbrand und
matratze am boden für kinder und mehr
sowas ist sehr simpel wie honig wo man
jetzt minimiert die zahlen dafür mehr
nur und halle wo alles zügig um sich für
die ganze familie
es ist irre und sicherlich viel billiger
und kostet als 300 franken pro monat
wirklich wirklich ein niedrige stand
aber der garde und der und
aussichtspunkt wirklich auch wieder so
ne irgendwie so nennt seine regierung
führe aber draußen fischer oder
kinderkrippe oder eine wo kurt methode
für den fall bliebe dann immer bei uns
im garten landet es hat irgendwie bis
eigentlich also im fall ganz ehrlich ich
fühle mich jetzt einfach
wenn sie zu wort ich bin sehr langweilig
ich genieße es und mit danke aber drüber
nach was man noch was wenn wir
zurückkommen und dann ist es für mich
wirklich schon ich will gerne
wiederholen
ob sie das hallen wohnen im zollhaus
leben werden ist noch offen
sicher ist die genossenschaft kalkbreite
will das experiment ahlen wohnen in
angriff nehmen
[Musik]